the speed you ever uh look into chat GPT
or AI or any of that what's that what's
GPT you don't know what chat really all
right so Chad GPT is like this
artificially intelligent like chat
software and we hit it up
to write a script because I'm gonna make
a weird tangent here uh I'm like I don't
know how many people watch dope sick but
that's like the most recent thing I've
watched you do and I thought that was
dope so huh Dope Sick the series weren't
you in that nah what am I thinking of uh
your honor oh yeah you're the you're
like the drug Runner yeah was that your
honor yeah why am I confusing that with
Dope Sick oh cause the dude
who was Michael Sackler
uh who's the older like the mob boss in
your honor uh Michael stulberg yeah yeah
he he was in Dope Sick yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah my bad
um
but anyway uh we all know you're a dope
actor so we had to write a comedy sketch
I don't know if you want to do it we can
just read it off the screen come on
let's do it can you bump up the text
size
all right so the the scene is just we're
on a road trip okay and someone busted
ass I should tell them what
this is though yeah so it's AI so like
yeah I I heard about this yeah yeah you
can ask it to do [ __ ] for you and it'll
just do it so I wrote the first part I
just wrote write a comedy script with
three characters Chad Hanks and will and
Cody they're on a trip together it's
going well until suddenly Aransas smell
fills the vehicle I don't want to spoil
the rest but all right and then it just
wrote this whole script for us okay I'm
says I'm driving yeah yeah you're
driving yeah okay okay
we're in the back seats yeah okay what
are we doing I think we're just chilling
okay listen to music yeah yeah
all right boys this is gonna be one a
hell of a trip hey man you said it Chet
I've got my snacks I've got my Tunes my
best buds what more could a guy ask for
ah yeah let's make some memories
oh my God what the hell is that someone
farted dude oh
I didn't do it oh neither did I oh come
on guys I know it was one of you I swear
to God it was not me man
I I mean yeah it wasn't us it must be
something in the car oh yeah right like
I'm gonna fall for that one
that's the argument becomes worse okay I
swear even though I have the beef sticks
I did not fart
I can't fart it's not physically
possible I don't have a butthole look
I'm telling you it wasn't me it was you
no dude why are you blaming us because
somebody has to take responsibility for
this I can't drive with this smell in
here
like my ass doesn't open I don't have a
hole Yeah right I've never farted in my
entire what
what do you mean oh God I'm sorry guys I
guess it was all of us
yeah my bad
same here
I guess we all let one rip huh
is that that's a genuine one that's not
because it says laughing but you're just
genuinely laughing
hey you're lying dude
Jesus yeah I guess so
hey I think we all deserve a snack break
after that
pull a car over check come on let's
share these beef sticks
wow
God damn it dude that was way more fun
than I thought it was going to be that's
great the future is here we thought we'd
get flying cars we get [ __ ] fart fart
jokes yeah free script dude scripts yeah
dude this is like some futuristic [ __ ]
we're living in yeah man like the Jets
and it wrote that in like two seconds
yeah wow it was it was like it was kind
of funny I mean it like ended you know
yeah
deserve a snack now yeah like I had a
nice like warm ending plot twist we all
farted yeah wow I was gonna make them it
was like that was like the [ __ ] when
you found out Kevin Spacey was Kaiser so
say
foreign
like [ __ ] Bruce Willis at the end of
Sixth Sense
imagine that just got spoiled for
someone they're like oh yeah I'm sorry
wait I haven't watched it yeah what the
[ __ ] man yeah a cool podcast episode I
just didn't like when Chet spoiled sixth
sense for me
I was halfway through
damn you [ __ ] with AI
dude uh I really don't really know that
much about it I did my little [ __ ] uh
what's it called the little portrait
yeah yeah like everybody yeah but I
didn't make it my my profile pic yeah I
didn't do that a lot of people did that
I don't trust the people that made their
their profile pic that why I don't know
dude it's just you know it's it's like
who are you you know
is that really you no you're not a
[ __ ] final you're not a martian you
know what I mean from Final Fantasy come
on now
you're just a normal dude yeah you know
yeah
who are you that's so funny you know is
that really you come on did you do it no
I didn't I never did it no I've I've uh
I've used other ones so I try to create
images just out of myself what are you
trying to prove me don't don't bring up
my Twitter
no bro go back
yeah because we always keep it until we
do something have you changed your
banner yeah I mean your banner because
that was a sick show
that was a great show that was in Ohio
right no that was yeah I know I was just
testing you
that was fun we were in a church yeah I
was in Wisconsin I'm pretty sure yeah I
was in a church you you signed with
soldier boy did you not
shout out to Soldier band we didn't
actually sign anything like there was no
paperwork but he was like I'm signing in
chat you know what I mean um but it was
it was cool man we did a song that was
cool Soldier uh yeah soldier's a good
dude soldier's a good dude is is music
in the plans for this year or is it kind
of just when it comes to me yeah yeah it
is are you still doing it yeah I'm about
to drop some [ __ ] actually oh really
yeah like uh like single full project
what is it right now I got a single it's
like uh
it's it's it's going to take people by
surprise man what is it what style
it's uh it's not it's not rap oh no what
is it I still got some rap about to put
out but this is not rap do you want to
talk about it are you trying to keep it
I'm just gonna let people I'm just gonna
let people figure it out just drop it on
it yeah I'm gonna drop it pretty soon
actually damn weeks a couple weeks yeah
I already shot the music video and
everything so is this like is this the
first time you talked about it uh kinda
no I I've talked about a little bit okay
on uh the Z-Wave interview but no I was
about to finally what did you go to
college together is that yeah I read
that right yeah we did you and Z way yep
oh sick yeah did you keep in touch after
college or did you guys kind of
reconnect nah yeah we we could yeah I
was like holy [ __ ] she's got a she's on
billboards and she's got her own show
last time I saw her I was like drunk as
[ __ ] at like my fraternities [ __ ] I
was probably like doing a [ __ ]
playing flip club or some [ __ ]
all of a sudden she's a [ __ ] got her
face on billboards and [ __ ] I was like
oh that's tight you know wow shut up
yeah shout out to zua how many clips
from that episode are hilarious that was
pretty funny that was pretty funny
people don't get that she's like playing
a character you know yeah I saw some
people that were like hating on her
because she's like you know that's like
a that's a character that she's playing
you know like the super like you know
sensitive like politically correct you
know person it's uh it's like satire
yeah it was great because
yeah everyone tagged me in your Joker
impression because I do a bad one and
they were like yours is good dude let's
hear it no no no it ain't that good come
on you asked me if I was ticklish dude
you could do it I mean that that was a
joke it's gonna be funny when you do
your Joker
will you do it if he does it yeah
you put on the spot this is the worst
[ __ ] ever you don't have to do it now I
know I brought it up but
when you see my father my father was a
drinker and he tickled me every day
he tickled me from here
she's dead that's really bad that's
really good a little dark that's really
bad my uncle
my uncle thought I was a really ticklish
guy yeah
[Laughter]
we don't have to we don't have to joke
off right now a joker off right now is
that what joke in office yeah it's just
a bunch of dudes sitting in the basement
trying to do Joker Impressions okay now
you go
dude that was sick my turn
what are you gonna do on your podcast
you said you're starting yeah yeah you
want to start yeah yeah yeah we shot the
first episode already oh how'd it go it
was good the guest is Big it's a big
guess who's like physically or
popularity can you tell us and we'll
bleep it if you don't want it I think I
already talked about it on fighter and
the kid but it's my dad oh yeah yeah I
think you said you were going to do it
yeah so if you did it the first guess is
my dad that's kind of sick yeah we
already did it how'd it go it's funny as
[ __ ] dude does it uh do you guys keep it
light-hearted you get deep we kind of
did a little we did it we did it all we
did it all got kind of deep we kept it
light it was funny told some stories
about me just being a [ __ ] when I was
younger it was funny is he ticklish
that'd be an awkward conversation